I am thrilled to have this guest here on
today he's been on the show before but
good man podcaster extraordinaire UFC
megastar now a commentator for ESPN and
soon-to-be father Chael Sonnen thank you
for joining the show sir I wouldn't miss
it buddy how are you I am doing well and
so are you it seems are you are you are
you happy right now you've gone through
some life transitions you know you were
you were tired from fighting your going
to be a dad
your Swit you've switched over to ESPN
are you are you happy you know I I'm
definitely largely happy all the time
but another care eristic that I would
describe myself as is tired I I'm very
fatigued and you talk about the ESPN on
East Coast versus West Coast up with the
travel I'm constantly different time
changes and I just find myself to be
tired I wish I could have a little bit
more sleep well I just take a sip of
that coffee get some product placement
going I'm holding one right now I was I
was trying not to since since we were on
your show but I might have to sneak a
slip in or two here yeah you know nobody
cares you could you could pull a John
Jones and pull out a line there and no
one would even judge you for it
so before we get into obviously the peds
that are in sports and for the audience
out there who might necessarily be
familiar with you you know you're you're
you are UFC megastar one of the biggest
draws ever a sports commentator but a
lot of people don't realize you've also
been outspoken as a conservative in in
ran for office um how big how big of a
defining factor is your worldview you
know your faith in your politics for
tailpiece on it well I mean that's just
who I am that I think anybody that would
answer that you know what what do you
believe in and and what are your your
principles and that is who that is who
you are so you know I'm a Catholic by my
religion I'm a conservative by choice I
don't apologize for either and one thing
that I am proud about though Stephen is
I I have reasons for believing what I
believe when when I was young it you
know you kind of grew up and just
believe whatever you're told whether
that was about the monster in the closet
or or whatever it may be but I got a
little bit older I did my own research
and I'm comfortable with the decisions
that I've made and I don't fault anybody
that has a different opinion than me or
but I would encourage
people to at least do a little research
don't just always go off of what you're
told in school or even what you were
told by your parents look into something
and figure out what you believe your
gentleman because see I do fault anyone
who has an opinion different than my own
you are going to be a father right
you're how far along is your your missus
now yeah you know she I consider myself
a father already that the the baby
unfortunately is in here yet I can't
wait for the little monster to arrive
but the lovely Miss Brittany is exactly
five months and one week and I always
get confused because these pregnancy
things go in we got 26 weeks twenty and
then somebody's got to get out his
calculator and do some shorthand five
months in one week so about another four
months to go and night we were just
talking about yesterday before we got
you here in the program how you looked
at the ultrasound and you said something
you may not remember but firstly how
impactful was that for you to look at
you know a beating heart and seeing that
for the first time as the first time dad
you know it's such a cool process and
it's a little bit annoying for anybody
that hasn't been through this is my
first time and I can tell you it's
always kind of annoying somebody's
telling you about it or however but
they'll also tell you when you go
through it you'll know what we mean and
it really is true ultrasound technology
Stephens been around for a long time but
this is my first time I I don't know
about it I've never been at the room and
and seen him do it and see the baby move
and open his hand and just do all these
things and be a little person so I mean
it's a cool experience it's it's it's
emotional it's life-changing it's all
those things that you hear it's I'm not
immune to any of it well let me ask you
this a lot of people have said this and
you obviously already were has it made
you more pro-life as it reinforced your
view there yeah it absolutely has you
know I was pro-life to start with uh but
here's the argument on pro-life you you
either argue that it's a child or it's
not if it if it is a life then we all
understand you must protect them when
you end up in a debate with somebody
with a different opinion that's the
stance they take they'll always say well
it's not alive if you ever have an
ultrasound it really defeats that
argument it's very clearly alive it's
moving and kicking in the little show
you right there there's the lungs
there's
the heart right there's a serum that
there's no way around that uh yeah you
know if you go through an ultrasound
process and you actually see it because
there's people you know you'll hear the
term ignore he's ignorant on any topic
the reality is yes people are sometimes
yeah we don't know we don't know until
we know we shouldn't insult somebody for
not knowing take the time and and tell
them and teach them something but if you
go through an ultrasound and you come
away and say that's not a life man
that's just a silly thing to say it for
sure it is yeah well if you come across
you know quotes from Elizabeth Warren or
Wendy Davis they want to not only be
able to end the life a couple of weeks
up but after that ultrasound that you've
even seen I mean that's what's so crazy
we're not just talking about even even
though it wouldn't make it right you
know we're not just talking about the
little blob of cells we're talking about
like what you said you know fingernails
and and even a personality I'm sure now
has Britney noticed a personality with
this baby yet is it a little more antsy
is it relaxed kicking a lot you know he
kicks a lot in the morning and the night
and she likes to tell me he's kicking it
and I tell her to change her verbage
that we're gonna say he's practicing he
likes to do two a days and he's training
in the morning and he's training in the
evening so you know she'll do that
sometimes she'll come up and grab my
hand and put it on her stomach and say
he's practicing would like that would
you want your boy to be a professional
fighter follow in your footsteps or
would you discourage him from that no I
would love it if he got into something
like that but you know whatever whatever
he wants to do is fine with me II's not
gonna be forced into anything but I
think sports are important on any level
or really here's the one thing I don't
like for young men even even guys I
coach or mentor will have got one minute
the biggest problem for young men
Stephen in our society period race
anything socioeconomic what doesn't
matter the biggest problem that young
men have is free time we cannot let a
kid come home from school and have
nothing to do for seven hours until
bedtime we've got to occupy their minds
and their bodies somehow yeah and I
would even argue that the best person to
help fill that free time of course would
also be a father we have a really big
problem with fatherless homes in the
country whether just completely absent
father or a father who refused to put a
ring on mommy's finger so he can you
know hit hit the nightclubs and
the line you're right a lot of free time
as a problem and you coach right you
coach out there in Oregon we've got to
go to a break here but you coach kids
and help a lot of impoverished youth
yeah that's right I coach the kids
wrestling team which you know to speak
to the impart it's it's not a it's not a
rich man's sport but we do two things
one we teach them a skill and two we
send them home tired well very nice and
we will be back to talk about peds in
sports at the top of the news a lot with
Crowder stay tuned
UFC superstar ESPN commentator podcaster
extraordinaire Chael peace son and thank
you for being here sir what mister
brother how are you I am doing well we
were just talking about before the break
our back problems so that's always an
issue but aside from that you know it's
a day above ground it's it's a big pain
sometimes to just sit too long but we
will manage through do you have actual
like disc issues in your back from
fighting for so many years you know I
don't have any disc issues but I was in
a I was in a wreck I was sitting in
traffic a number of years ago and I got
rear-ended by a fully loaded gravel
truck with a fully loaded trailer I was
the first one hit it and mounted into a
five car pileup I hit the guy in front
of me hit the cart you know the domino
effect and it's just kind of always been
a little bit offset since then yeah a
little bit off will happen with a truck
full of concrete going into yeah you're
fortunate I saw coming at me too I was I
was at an absolute stop and I saw it my
rearview that's gone Oh boom got got hit
geez well hopefully recover yeah I've
got a couple of herniated discs and all
that's good that's the problem you know
the thing is obviously I'm not a pro
athlete but I've done grappling
submission wrestling for years you know
and it's a great sport to take part in
it does keep you active it gives you
something to get up for but it does not
lend itself to longevity it really
doesn't especially it you know what are
you walking around 220 it's about what I
am it's it's a different game than other
than a featherweight you're right you're
right and you know it seems like with
each year it's almost to the day of my
birthday three more pounds three more
find three pounds may not sound like a
lot but the years go quickly and it adds
up and if you're talking about back pain
weight matters yeah well LeBron just
lost a few pounds I think 20 or so
because of he said that he didn't like
the the you know the impact from the
joints and he's only playing a you know
a girly sport like
get ball so I can imagine when you're
actually in there fighting a guy well
there it is right there yeah you had a
little tiff with LeBron not long ago I
remember but then you said he made up
for it we made up for he made it he made
it right and I and I accept his apology
with what was it that he said didn't he
say something to your missus yeah well
then to initiate the whole thing yes but
to for the apology if you want to call
it that it was it was actually he helped
out a friend of mine that he had no idea
was a very completely random act of
kindness that he did for somebody in Las
Vegas was a very good friend of mine
named Paige and they say it's the
thought that counts he actually tried to
help her out with a room key because she
had lost her ID and he went as far as to
offer three bribes to the front desk
put the cash down and everything the
bribes were rejected she never got the
room key but it's back to the you know
it's the thought that counts and for his
good heart he's forgiven okay so we're
not gonna get into what he actually said
they get you angry in the first place
we're not okay all right let's go
obviously right now this is the top deal
in the news so again we spoke with jail
we got you on the show before then but
your longtime rival Anderson Silva and
you're a gentlemen I you don't need to
play the gentlemen card it's not they're
not enough people listening here just
tested positive now for two banned
steroids what do you make of that
there's a lot of speculation going on
what was your initial reaction when you
heard it well just to put it in
perspective for everybody that maybe
doesn't follow the news on the Anderson
as you're speaking of but we're about 12
hours into this whole thing so my
opinion and your opinion we need to
reserve the right to change our opinion
when we're confronted with new evidence
which is certainly going to happen as
this thing continues on but you know
look there's there's two sides to this
here there's there's two parts of at
least first off and again a quick
timeline for everybody
Anderson Silva had what's known as a
compound fracture in his leg right his
leg snapped me and the bone had a clean
break in happy
only thing that kept his shin and his
foot connected to his body was his skin
right as graphic as that sounds it's
very relevant to this now Anderson has
an obligation a moral obligation to
himself to put his health first he needs
to do whatever he can to repair that leg
I think we could all stipulate to that
whether it's free market or black market
if it helps his leg even if he's got a
lien on science good for him
okay path however there the second part
of it is sport
there are rules within the sport and
they have to be followed no matter what
it's real black and white and you don't
know you don't often get to come to the
table and go well yeah but there there
is a reason for that you don't get to do
that right it sounds as though he took
something that's banned it sounds as
though it's an illegal steroid and he's
gonna have to answer for that so it's a
little bit of a two-part thing well done
one second
as you just mentioned something that you
and I have talked about I've heard you
mentioned before a lot of people don't
understand right and we'll get into the
fact because a lot of people will say
well chili can't compliment us he's a
hypocrite and we'll get into that but
the difference between a banned
substance and an illegal steroid what he
was taking to the best of my
understanding at least one of those
substances was an illegal steroid am i
right wrong and what's the difference
according to what he's accused of yes he
had I believe it was two things in his
system I believe they are both illegal
steroids to my understand in America he
came from South America again there
could be some conversation on laws there
but by our standards and my
understanding yes that's correct well
over there it's you know yeah I got some
back pain here's some steroids in Brazil
it's a little bit more free rein that
that's that's a true statement I don't
actually know what the specific laws on
this are but it is true that that their
regular bodies are a lot looser than
ours well both in the literal and the
figurative sense I've trained with
enough Brazilians to see them coming in
with six-packs and veins reptilian it
year round so they can walk you know
Coco Cabana and a speedo they're not
they're not even the guys who aren't
athletes so yeah you know chill as a
commentator ESPN has to reserve judgment
but I'll I'll do it I'll indict an
entire name
people steroid users so listen a lot of
people will say okay well jail this is
hypocritical because you left the sport
under a cloud right you tested positive
for banned substances what do you say to
those people I know you veered right
into this right you said it's the only
way to handle it but the substances that
you had taken testosterone you were
cleared you were under a doctor and then
it was then it was banned right and then
you tested positive for other substances
did you only take those to get off TRT
or had you been on those for a longer
amount of time and were those illegal
steroids or just banned substances well
I've never I've never taken any illegal
steroids or even been accused of that
okay everything I took was accurate I
was never falsely accused I took
everything that I they suggested I took
and frankly more over the years you know
I I don't even know if I ever went to my
doctor my litmus test has never been to
cross-reference that advice with an
athletic commission if my doctor
prescribed it to me I that was it and I
slept fine at night I never even had a
bad conscience about it
but that doesn't mean it wasn't against
the rules and and that is a confusion
you'll hear the term somebody took in an
illegal substance what most people will
believe is your talk about illegal by
the law standards no illegal can be
perfectly legal it just can be against
the rules of the sport and each
Commission can set up their own rules so
keeping track of it can be very
complicated now that wasn't what
happened in my case in my case I knew
full well I couldn't take it I just
thought I could have both sides of it I
can I can make myself feel better and I
can compete I can get out of my system
on time that's a flawed logic and I'm
not arguing that I'm just speaking to
the point that guys do get confused in
it a reasonable person is going to
believe if it's legal I'm allowed to
take it they're also going to believe
it's if it's illegal I can't take it and
what we're finding out through this
process is that's not true either
there's some absolutely imprisoning
criminal substances that oddly are
allowed for the sport with some of these
athletic commissions and there's also
perfectly
things over-the-counter as minor as
tylenol where people have lost Olympic
gold medals over right that's true even
caffeine I understand in the Olympic by
the Olympic Committee there's a limit
and I think it's about two two cups of
coffee right is considered a banned
substance anything more than that that's
right I believe the way I heard it was
two shots of espresso but coffee would
also be a fair statement uh oh my gosh
you have a venti at Starbucks you're
you're pissin hot well which I do every
morning I'm at the coffee house I'm
holding that right now as we're doing
this interview I'm at the coffee house
every morning at 6:00 a.m. when they
open up the good news on caffeine is it
gets out of your system in about 15
minutes yeah I don't think I've ever
heard or any of your viewers have heard
of somebody testing positive however if
a random test were to come within that
15-minute window
they could have their license pulled
over caffeine that that's an accurate
statement just straight up do you um
still bother you at all what the things
people say or when you left the sport
and that controversy happened yeah you
know I never felt good about here's one
thing that happens is human nature
whenever whenever you're in the hot spot
whenever you're caught in some red tape
and you're wrong yeah you feel it
there's also a relief to being
accurately accused you know the guys I
feel bad for the guys that are falsely
accused I wasn't in that spot man I was
guilty and it brought me shame you know
whenever you have shame it's very hard
to come clean right even even when you
want to come clean it should yeah
there's a internal battle that goes on
and it takes a little bit to get there
you know to bring it back to the
Anderson situation if he took these
substances again he not only has a right
to take it he's got an obligation to
himself if it's about sure it is why if
he's not in professional sports where
he's whacking on some other guy
obviously is what people will say but
that's that's the second side of the
first thought you got to put health
comes first sport comes second or sport
comes way down the list but health
certainly comes first right he has the
right and even an obligation to cure
himself and if he's got a lien on
science for that good for science going
good for the discovered it but but hole
I do want to finish this thought that
doesn't mean you can blend it with sport
I'm not arguing that he should be able
to well no that's and that's a
that's it situation yeah I understand it
well let me ask you this you know the
substance that he tested positive first
off complete speculation I am aware of
this but I'm asking for your opinion do
you think Anderson was on something when
you fought him I can tell you I can tell
you on the substance issues the the
rules get very blurred and it'll tell
you why they have something now called
out-of-competition testing right it the
rule used to be in the rule when I
started and came through and one of the
problems I had was not adapting to the
changes but it used to just be in
competition meaning what's in your
system on fight night time matter if you
were to come in and go hey listen I
gotta tell you guys when I was in high
school I did and then fill in the blank
they go out we don't care you know well
bad news when I was in college I did it
again the guy we don't care so right off
the bat you understand time does matter
there is a time period of which all is
forgiven
right the confusion has come in what is
that time period and I accept that these
are the rules and we must operate within
them I do believe there's a conversation
to be had that you can't just ban all
medication from a person a person does
not have one second one second or I hate
to do this but the question was do you
believe do you think someone else a gun
to your head do you think Anderson had
used before or anything this is a
one-time deal when you fought him do you
think he was on something if you have to
guess what he I can't answer with a yes
or no Stephen because here's why here's
why the if you're saying that a guy
never took a banned substance in his
life that's a silly statement
particularly in the context of you and I
just established that tylenol caffeine
IV prep these things are all banned
substances but what about these
substances that he was taking you know I
really don't know me and I can tell you
this on Anderson Silva that the human
body doesn't get better with age
right that's reality we start to decline
as humans and particularly as athletes
right around 25 years old if you're real
lucky you might push that to 27 or 28
the good news is science and medicine
have come along
and decided the world does not belong to
18 to 25 year olds but that you can
extend your career right beyond so if
you're asking me if he took something
there's two tests that you take Stephen
the first the first test is not all
right the urine drug test the first test
is the visual when a guy takes his
t-shirt off and gets into the ring or
steps on the scale you look at him if a
guy got better with time you can't do
that on your own Anderson Silva's body
doesn't appear to have changed at all so
a reasonable person would conclude that
whatever he was on now he was on before
but there's no evidence to support that
no I get it it's entirely speculation
and that's why I tried to preface it
with that to be fair as opposed to the
people on the Gotcha stations who lit it
without bees listen we're gonna go to a
break here and we will be right back
because I want to continue down this
line and even take it to John Jones back
with chill son and we were talking
before the break about peds and sports
Anderson Silva is obviously breaking
news but so we speculated a little bit
there I certainly did one thing I will
say having read up on the drugs that
Anderson did use you know one of those
substances if you look at it actually
one of its symptoms
one of the side effects is that it can
cause over calcification it can actually
cause bones to become weaker and more
prone to breaking did you know that no I
had heard that and that's where you have
all of the you know people speculating
it again it is speculation you have a
bunch of mouth breathers who've never
had an armbar in their life on Sherdog
acting like they're now medical experts
or biochemists but that is an actual
side effect of that one drug that he had
taken which sort of makes it interesting
I know listen you hate to ever drag
someone's name through the mud obviously
you've had some things happen but it is
a little bit fun as the news unfolds
let's be honest you know I'll tell you
this about myself I I was asked that too
I would soon as you test positive for
something people will want to say it was
over your your whole career and my
response is that's fair that's a fair
statement if you get hit with something
it runs you all the way back in time
right the reality is as science and
medicine change you're constantly taking
new things are they within the rules or
not you know I think that's all a good
question nobody's totally clear on what
the
rules are I don't think you are I knew
prior to Anderson testing positive how
to pronounce these substances let alone
where they allowed or not so you kind of
learn as you go but I do think that's a
fair statement you know I don't think a
guy should I don't think it helps a guy
to ever come out of go no no no this was
a one time or or I only did our man they
just caught me in a bed just call it
what it is man you took it you got
caught be in and that that's what
happened we'll see how Anderson handles
it but I think when somebody at least
for me when somebody tried to say things
even if it wasn't accurate I think I
still deserve it if you test positive
and somebody wants to run that back all
the way to when I started my nine years
old I don't think that guy's wrong
everything you just said well my
takeaway was chill Sunnah knows how to
use you or I properly good use of
grammar yeah I want to be a little gone
with the you and me but that was
appropriate fun dip the producer he's
out right now who's on the show he will
constantly correct my grammar there
there isn't very simple on a rule on how
to follow that my mother was a
schoolteacher so I know that rule but
but a lot of people don't so very good I
appreciate you picket you want to know
one that bothers me when somebody says I
could care less oh I hate that if you
could care less that means you're not at
the bottom of your cares right that you
have room to care it's I couldn't I
could not care less I mean I'm at the
bottom of the pit on caring the worst
for me I think that any man who goes
about with the word irregardless on his
lips deserve to be roasted with his own
Thanksgiving turkey over-exaggerated
right it's a redundant there's no need
to guesstimate right all all grammatical
infractions far worse than steroid use
mind you instead of remind you I didn't
really even think of them that one that
that one's an annoying one yes well I'm
learning I'm learning say we always
learn is we need actor and as the
radiance of our show or going down the
channel let's let's go back back up so
it'll more fun well not even just
steroids right okay really quickly
because we don't want to spend too much
time on the technical side of it John
Jones tested positive
for cocaine that was a big deal you
fought John Jones you hosted a reality
show against Jon Jones ok so we know
that but I do want to get to this
because a lot of the conspiracy
theorists again online say that you knew
that and you tweeted out John if you
keep telling lies about me I'm going to
start telling the truth about you and at
the weigh-ins when usually people
rehydrate themselves with Pedialyte or
Gatorade or something like that you were
drinking a can of coke looking him
straight in the face
how long have you or let's say people in
the sport known about this there are
rumors circulating that people known for
a long time as this guy's been a fan of
Columbian gold I would tell you this
Gatorade is for suckers Pedialyte is for
babies and coca-cola is for gangsters
and there was absolutely no correlation
other than coca-cola had sponsored me
and it tastes delicious
that's uh that's the famous Arnold line
in pumping iron milk is for papists it
yeah well milk milk that's not a fair
statement milk will keepers be your
bones strong melts a good thing make
sure you drinking your milk butBut I
don't know why a grown man would drink
Pedialyte it tastes terrible and it's
for bait there's a infant on the bottle
there's like a four-year-old baby on the
bottle of Pedialyte and I see these
grown man sipping it it's just weird
well you have to see something though
here chilli I mean I love you but yep I
have to point out some inconsistency
with your there drinking a coke right
next to your dietitian Mike Dolce who
basically says you might as well be
giving yourself cancer what does he do
when you did or is he is he not as
stringent behind the scenes is he a
little more relaxed he was so mad
Stephen don't about and he told me ahead
of time that that was gonna make him mad
I did it under I didn't take him as
sincere I thought it was like a joke mad
you know elbow up a wink wave we had
dinner after that she he didn't come to
dinner he bruised oopps
with me he said well if you don't want
to listen to me there's no point in me
being there I didn't understand that he
would care that much however now this is
true forget the sponsorship forget look
real talk real quick coca-cola is one of
the most ice-cold coca-cola I could swim
in it Stephen I could jump in a pool of
coca-cola and be so happy
I want to put into context I was 17
pounds overweight
22 hours before I made the way so I lost
17 pounds in 22 hours to explain to you
my level of thirst and dehydration I
couldn't speak because my mouth gonna
have any saliva I was that the imagine
how good an ice-cold coca-cola tasted
right there there's one shot in your
life to enjoy a coca-cola that much and
I had passed it up my previous fight was
also a title fight with Anderson Silva
Dolce took my coca-cola way I literally
resented him for it for an entire year
until I had that way and again I said I
can't do it I got I gotta have a pop
there you go god I have it pop you know
I always wondered in the Pacific
Northwest if you guys said soda or pop
and you just answered my question
back to John Jones version of coca-cola
yeah I know hilarious segue well done
very clever yeah he likes the cocaine
listen here's my deal with John Jones I
would love him to be on the show I don't
think you know I I don't think he knows
me from the Tom Dick or Harry down the
street but you know when you go out with
the Bible verses tattooed on you and you
go out and you talk about wanting to be
a role model and saying you know I'm
never gonna be caught with a DUI and
then you test positive for cocaine now
cocaine again there's the
differentiation between in competition
and out of competition whereas you know
Nick Diaz tested positive for pot it
could have been fighting blitzed for all
we know very skilled those those Diaz
brothers with John Jones what's the real
deal with him who is the real John Jones
that's a speculation he's lost a lot of
fans and and how rampant is not just
peds how rampant are drugs in sports is
it more common than we think I think for
marijuana does cocaine is a weird one
for me I'm from Portland Oregon I've
never not only have I never put my eyes
on coke I've never been offered it or
around somebody that's like hey man I
just dig that's for us in Oregon that's
a Hollywood thing we only see cocaine in
the movies we only we only picture it
and it's everything that you see in
Hollywood is what my vision of coke
however we're known here in Oregon for
having good marijuana I don't understand
the marijuana argument I resist it fully
that the laws are changing and evolving
and I'm just gonna have to say fine to
that but to your point I don't know that
drugs are very rampant I know when you
speak of John Jones look he's a young
guy that stumbled into an enormous
amount of success he was a college
dropout I don't mean that as a slide to
him I mean that it's more of a
compliment and a guy that still stuck
with some goals and was able to turn it
around but he was caught in that period
of time where you're going out you're
having fun you're doing these types of
things and one thing about an athlete
Stephen what one of the the dark sides
of an athlete is you never have to grow
up you get to continue to be in the
locker room sports or a game and you can
talk about it and being a professional
all you want sports are for children and
they're a game and a very select few
people get it continue that into adult
life but it largely doesn't propel them
to professionalism it does just the
opposite it just kind of allows you to
stay a kid longer and I think John's
having some growing pains that are
getting caught in front of the world and
it's embarrassing but the good news and
there really is no spin here that the
real good news is he got caught man if
you're hooked on cocaine I think we can
both agree you don't want to be yeah
well you know listen I spent a lot of
time in the media entertainment industry
so it's not as foreign to me as it is to
you I've never touched it but I've as a
matter of fact I've moved I've moved
cities because of how rampant cocaine
wasn't industries that would surprise
people to get away from it that being
said I mean the big criticism is is the
kid is fake about it he went into rehab
for half a day do you really think I'd
like to see someone learn because he's
possibly the best athlete ever in the
sport of mixed martial arts it doesn't
seem like he really cares that much this
is not right this is very wrong but to
pretend this isn't funny he checked into
Reid
he signed in and he signed his ass right
back out they can't force you to stay in
rehab they also can't disclose when you
leave there's absolute and inhibiting
reasons to go in so when he wants to
make a statement go back checked into
rehab
he never said I stayed in rehab he never
said I completed rehab right that could
possibly be the funniest thing that he
say inappropriate I'm not giving this a
pass I'm not weighing judgment at all
but that may be the single most humorous
thing I'm that straight out of a movie
the dude checked in signed this sheet
and walked back to the Bentley and drove
home that's a gangster move any way you
look at it that's what that is as not as
Bentley if you're talking about that
picture he said it wasn't as Bentley so
how dare you bring your incorrect facts
to light it with Crowder sir it's just a
funny story man and the thing with John
Jones and I was right and a lot of times
with John Jones you know it's like
anybody else all you do is talk about
the bad I don't mean to build a guy up
that just went to I'm not giving a pass
for any of that but I was around and day
and night on a reality show seven days a
week we we spent holidays together and
fell over one Halloween which I know
isn't a holiday but it's a big day if
you have kids you don't get to see him
dressed up at home we also spent
Thanksgiving together we literally sat
down we had weather took John and I cut
the turkey and scooped up the potatoes
for everybody the point I'm trying to
make I really got to know him and he was
an excellent guy he was nice to people
he took time he was generous he was
gracious he also liked to go out at
night I understand there's two sides of
him but I do want to make sure the whole
story gets told if he was here right now
he would make you laugh he would be if
he's a fun guy and I think he needs to
mature a little bit and I'll finish with
this thought on John Jones
to your point about him being fake and
he does get called that there's some
truth to that he has an image of Louie
wants to be but he's not that guy I
think we can all relate to that we all
want to be somebody and sometimes we'd
fall a little short right his deals with
with criticism because he's in the media
he's got certain sponsors and brands and
he believes he needs to portray a
certain image I believe not only on a
personal level would he somehow be
relieved and
kind of added the closet if you will but
I also believe on a professional lab the
level sales would do better if he just
came out and said look I party all night
I barely ever go to the gym and I'll
whip anybody's ass that wants to step in
that cage with me all three of those
statements are true and they would also
make him endearing yeah I don't know
about that I mean you look at like
George st. Pierre and here's one thing I
will say that bothers me and I don't say
this to insult you because obviously you
fought Anderson and you know but
everyone's saying he's without a doubt
the greatest of all time not only as a
Montrealer but George st. Pierre when
you and I had this conversation remember
at your place in Oregon with macdanne
jur waffles was sitting right there
right there there's a good dog I've got
my dog here hopper in here he's actually
like Ronda Rousey's dog a dog or
Argentino big incredible athlete if you
could put him in a human he would be
like John Jones turned up to 11 or the
crazy dog that's awesome super sweet
completely even my dog is Owen 7 in
street fight 6 against cat against a
horse was very sweet he means well he
does mean well my dog hates horses
I don't even wrote my point is we start
talking about dogs I was saying George
st. Pierre oh ok yes so greatest-ever is
a phrase you said I remember right as we
were prepping to shoot this this video
on legalizing MMA in New York and we
have to go in a minute and a half you
said I've never seen an athlete like
that in my life and I know many Olympic
medalists now in retrospect looking at
everyone's career don't you think
someone could argue that the guy who
left undefeated never tested hot was a
great ambassador to the sport highest
pay-per-view draw wouldn't you have to
give it to st. Pierre at this point
until maybe Jones passes him by yeah I
don't think there is any argument it
definitely goes it definitely goes to
George st. Pierre and George st. Pierre
was ranked number one in the world pound
for pound there was a press conference
done and they said no Anderson's the
best and and our president Dana White
made this whole argument that is his
opinion but the entire media then
shifted they drop George from 1 to 2 to
lift Anderson from 4 to 1 Anderson's a
fantastic fighters isn't a commentary on
him but if you want to talk about the
grades I
fought Anderson twice I've worked out
with Saint Pierre just call it like it
is it's George okay final thought here
if you were to have fought George st.
Pierre both of you and your prime
speculate how do you think that would
have gone do you think because he's a
lot smaller than you do you think it
would have been close well I'll tell you
this I worked out with George st. Pierre
and it was competitive and close but
George got the best of me he was the
strongest ox it was shocking to feel his
grip I remember when he would grab ahold
him it was like being caught in a vise
grip he was also a lot quicker than me
because of that size factor and and it
was enough to upset me I remember
driving home in my car that night
thinking I need to get my hands on this
guy again I think I need if I could beat
him but if you want the reality of our
one private workout that that only Kenny
Florian was witness to I will admit st.
Pierre was impressive
and you know what would have been so I
imagine even harder to take about that
is he would have been so nice with a
child don't worry about it that's gonna
be a better day for you tomorrow you
know he did all of that and he told me
about oh you know I went that last night
that did not get home till 5:00 in the
morning I very tight you know he did
this whole thing and it's like okay I'm
just going to the shower yeah no we
weren't close you know he paid me some
compliments afterwards too but you know
if I was to be fair about it man George
George was the victor that day if I'm
being fair about it you just made George
st. Pierre sound like the Iron Sheik
I've only got one accent what the
nationale are at this and I'm attempting
to do and Jake I could be doing you it
comes out the same way yeah well we
should phrase that differently next time
but before we go podcaster
extraordinaire obviously commentator for
ESPN noted conservative good man where
can people best find you they can find
me on Twitter you know what I'm I'm on
Twitter constantly uh son and CH s o NN
e and CH thank you very much jail and
look for to having you back brother
happy to help if you liked this video
congratulations you in the internet with
an attention span of more than 30
seconds but subscribe we've got more
videos like this and somewhere I just
look like Mohammed and beat my
six-year-old wife for historical
accuracy